citizens of the reject nation welcome to
another koi's comic corner today it's a
big one this is not an easy one this
took years of thought and a lot of
stress this week for me to curate this
we're going to break down the top
25 comic book movies crossing genres
crossing studios i'm wearing a saga
shirt because they don't make saga
movies yet so it's non-denominational
this shirt is switzerland now please if
you like this video do leave a like
that's how i know you like it it
literally helps me know this was worth
doing also please subscribe again that's
so greg knows that you liked it and it's
worth me being here there's a series of
ways to let us know you are liking this
content my favorite of which is leaving
a comment when you leave a comment i get
to know what you want to see more of
you're the co-host of this whole journey
you tell me what you want to see more of
hint 26 through 50 50 through 75 top 100
let greg know i want to do this longer
25 was a negotiation let's get to 50
minimum hear greg laughing nervously
because it's coming and before we get
into it i want to thank everyone who's
been following me on tick tock those 30
second 15 second minute long three
minute videos like this you guys are
saying you're coming over from reject
nation it means the world to see you
guys jump from here and there and cross
discuss anyway let's get into it
[Music]
number
25 let's start at spicy you lovelies my
number 25 favorite comic book movie is
zack snyder's the snyder cut of justice
league this film i think captured the
greatest parts of the snyder experience
the visuals are lush the world is built
out it is scope-tastic it is such an
enormous undertaking in a very positive
way in creating it and experiencing it
is an hours and hours long experience
that feels both like a movie and like a
mini-series it's the greatest of both
and i love that it really differentiates
itself from marvel movies from other dc
movies from indie comic movies it feels
like snyder's vision of these demigods
of these deities of this world and you
get his specific take on each one of
these characters in a grand scale that
also doesn't feel like it sacrifices
these characters in the medium of comic
books it feels true to the comic true to
his vision and all that feels enormous
like really no other comic book movie
gets to because of the size of this
project love me some snyder cut number
24 a movie that is foundational to comic
book movies being what they are today
now this list is off of my favorites i
am keeping in mind what they did for the
journey as well as what i rewatch often
and what i think objectively now in 2022
is a good movie so certain movies that i
don't think held up or don't revisit or
don't watch as often they don't make the
cut just because they were first but
this movie i think was very early on and
does hold up and is very important so it
hits all those very important marks it's
spider-man 2. spider-man 2 is one of the
best of that era's villains and then
that villain coming back meant the world
because we got so much time to dive into
alfred molina's doc it gave us a very
important mixed melancholy with humor
with you know comic book silver age
flavor spider-man through sam raimi's
vision and it gave us a more leveled out
tobey maguire spider-man you guys know
if you ever want to see me break down
the three spider-man videos leave that
comment because spider-man as far as i
see him toby maguire is pretty far from
how i personally koi perceives
spider-man so it's hard for me when i
don't perceive spider-man that way to
really adjust into this world but the
way sam raimi and toby work together the
world they built really sings best in
spider-man 2. number 23 is much more
recent and much more bombastic in both
blood gore and glory it is the suicide
squad james guns the suicide squad is i
think what you get when you let an
insane comic book property an insane
director and an insane budget go hog
wild and i think that's what comic
movies can be comic books are
about your imagination the space between
the panels is what you're experiencing
in the story when a director with the
vision of james gunn gets characters
that aren't as beholden to continuity
you get things like a peacemaker show
you get things like characters that talk
to rats as your big lead you get polka
dot man as one of the favorite
characters of the modern superhero era
played masterfully by david dasmulchen
because that world fits so uniquely you
get idris elba's bloodshot in a way that
you could only get in a movie this
insane this r-rated this movie doesn't
just represent the suicide squad to me
this movie represents full creative
artistic freedom for the medium of comic
book movies with someone well deserving
to go hog wild love the suicide squad
number 22 is probably going to get me a
little bit of sass but i'm ready for it
i got the shoulders let's get after it
iron man 3 is in my opinion the
maturation of the mcu this is a movie
that looks at the psychology of going
through trauma this is the movie that
takes the most charming cool awesome guy
in the mcu and puts him through the
ringer because he has ptsd of seeing
something that would shock you we're
looking at these characters that are
going through larger than life
situations and we're just watching them
soldier on for a little bit we're
getting through phase one we're building
to something but if you're gonna feel
something if you want to mature a
universe if you want to see the shell
shock if you want to see the
ramifications of these actions you need
movies like iron man 3 and this movie is
so well handled with shane black working
with downey jr again after kiss kiss
bang bang and he's making this universe
for adults as well as entertaining kids
the barrel of monkeys airplane scene is
still one of the best action sequences
in the mcu but you've also got a great
world building with don cheadle and
downey jr you've also got a great
extremist story line there are some
flaws i do not love the killing and fire
breathing i don't love that they changed
out the villain but those flaws are far
outweighed by the excellence that is the
tone shift of the entire mcu that
doesn't get enough credit this movie is
exceptional 21 is an incredible
adaptation of an incredible two issue
comic book art days of future past is
literally only two issues and they're
two of the most important issues in the
history of comic books this movie is an
avengers level event this movie has time
travel this movie has the culmination of
the singer x-men movies to date and i
really honestly think it blends the best
of matt vaughn's incredible x-men first
class which almost made this list with
the best of brian singer's universe if
you think about that when they made it
they literally made an avengers level
movie at fox trusting in their x-men
universe trusting in us the audience
trusting in their incredible cast and
you've got mcavoy opposite patrick
stewart both of xavier that's insane to
think about from x-men in 2000 to 20 i
think it was like 16. they were able to
get us to be able to enjoy that world it
does have some flaws don't love the
mcavoy heroine storyline don't love the
fact that they use a wolverine instead
of shadow cat those two things are taken
out this would be in the top 10 for me
this movie is a solid a it is so close
and it is clearly my number 21 with
belzona we're into the top 20 my number
20 is wonder woman this movie does an
impeccable job introducing us to an
entire world this takes the world of
thimascara and makes it real the boat
scene between gal gadot and chris pine
is some of the most charming acting i've
ever seen much less in building a
relationship in a comic book movie the
way they handle no man's land the way
they show the strength and femininity in
action the way they show the power of
diana prince the way they do all of this
while also building out a great
supporting cast while also building out
a world war one story that puts her in
our universe establishes a fun
continuity and is a great launching
point unfortunately it didn't launch
into as good of a sequel but what it did
do was finalize how important wonder
woman is and gave a hero for little
girls and little boys and adult boys and
adult girls the world over this is a
very important movie that had to stick
the landing and did there are some
issues with the third act again if this
movie didn't have some of those third
act issues it'd be even higher but since
i do struggle with that last boss fight
i have to to knock it down a few pegs
but it's still a top 20 for me favorite
comic book film number 19 staying within
the dc extended universe we've got my
personal favorite dc eu film shazam
to me superhero films are about pound
responsibility to me they're about
staying young and what you believe in
when you're a kid and not losing that
sense of innocence and staying childlike
without being childish some comic book
movies are childish this movie is
childlike to a t i'm also a sucker for
an orphan story i think family is so
important i think that the way you
connect with family is so important this
movie did the opposite of the usual
hollywood foster shaming this is about
how family isn't blood it's who welcomes
you it's also at moments very scary it
balances an 80s ambliness tone i love
the villain and mark strong i love the
supernatural elements i love that it's a
great launching point and it gives us
arguably as good of casting as your
downey juniors and your ryan reynolds i
don't think zach levi gets enough credit
for being a pitch perfect shazam in
lesser hands this movie doesn't work but
because zach levi is that inner child
day in and day out and is a king of
comic-con nerddam he gets this movie and
david f sandberg directing him makes it
sing throw in some jack dylan grazer
shazam number 18 is the movie
that i think allowed for the greater mcu
i give spider-man a lot of credit i give
x-men movies a lot of credit but i think
the movie that was sneakily a comic book
movie that people just thought was a
[ __ ] and vampire movie number 18 is
blade this movie is so memorable this
movie is seared into your brain if
you've ever seen it the opening
nightclub scene is i think still the
greatest opening scene to any comic book
movie it gives you a tone it gives you a
badass lead it establishes the villain
it lets you know the ride you're gonna
go on the soundtrack to this movie is a
banger this movie feels cool because
blade is cool it builds out an entire
universe remarkably quickly it allows
you to feel like you're in this world
and it predates the matrix it's got so
much of that flair that trench coat
awesomeness that the 90s were defined by
but it did it first and it did it with a
character that's from a comic book that
a lot of people didn't even realize at
the time this movie doing well and
newline doing well allowed for the mcu
to really get a launching point and i
think honestly mahershala ali is the
only person that could possibly keep up
with what wesley snipes did because
wesley snipes is blade and this movie is
so important number 17 is i think one of
the most loyal adaptations to the feel
of a character while still being true to
its medium and still being true to the
things that came before it that is
batman mask of the phantasm not only
does this give us my personal favorite
journey with kevin conroy's batman today
some incredible mark hamill joker but it
also gives us a new villain i love the
phantasm dylan who only just came back
in the comic books in this great tom
king realm which i definitely recommend
but it's also a story that is unique to
this arc but also resonates with so many
classic archetypal batman stories it is
a very summer it's now that's what i
call batman you cannot know batman and
throw in mask of the phantasm and you
get the character much more than the
average movie this movie is i think the
definition of batman and i think the
live action movies have been chasing it
largely ever since you throw in a really
fun twist that actually totally
resonates and an incredible pace that
works for adults and kids alike batman
mask of the phantasm is the bar in
animated or live action comic book film
number 16 is the first time i remember
sitting in a movie theater and going i
don't have any like nerd notes like i
you know obviously always have little
qualms and things but with spider-man i
had my moments my toby issues with x-men
one i was like wow this mix x2 i think
really was was one to nail it whereas
blade doesn't have a strong continuity
right like blade the runs of the comic
books never really establish a singular
narrative which is why it's beautifully
free in character x-men is the opposite
x-men has tons of messy continuity
that's always fighting each other x-men
is a giant soap opera it's very easy to
get wrong x-men 2 captured the world
that hates and fears them it adapted
very lovingly god loves man kills it
gave us a taste of berserker rage as
hard as you could have gone in a pg-13
rating basically it learned everything
it could have from x-men one evolved
improved and gave us a sequel that not
enough people give credit as one of the
great sequels this movie
is the reason we continued on with comic
book movies going well blade might have
kicked the door open but this lovingly
took off running x-men 2 still
exceptional number 15 is a comic book
splash page come to life captain america
civil war so many people come at me like
that's overrated doesn't hold up this is
a movie that in to building the mcu
gives us hero vs hero with reliable
reasons iron man has justification for
his actions and builds on the character
we've lived with for years for eight
years for a long time captain america
very justified in his actions he is
living up to all the standards we've
established with chris evans as captain
america their conflict is justified and
that they were friends makes it
beautifully well orchestrated by baron
zemo masterfully played by daniel bruhl
who also by the way took out t'chaka
opening the film bringing us in one of
the most incredible introductions of not
just black panther but spider-man while
weaving an incredible web of action
intrigue espionage and launching into
where we go with infinity war and
endgame in the giant tapestry of phase
one through three the x through the
center is civil war and you gotta put
respect on its name and not enough
people do 15 civil war [ __ ] slaps
number 14 is one of the most important
comic book movies ever made it is a film
that started to truly legitimize genre
content this was a movie nominated for
best picture by the academy awards this
is a movie that made so much over a
billion dollars this is a movie that i
personally saw four times in theaters
because i kept wanting to discover more
this movie has a perfect soundtrack this
movie has a perfect cast this movie has
a perfect villain this movie has a
perfect protagonist this movie is black
panther if you watch black panther you
notice that not only does the entire
ensemble cast have their own individual
beautiful subplots not only does
chadwick masterfully navigate being
t'challa as a regal king
intellectualizing everything while
watching from the background while never
becoming the background he's able to be
equal parts jason bourne james bond and
the talented mr ripley he is watching he
has calculated he is navigating all of
this set to a giant summer spectacle
blockbuster with ludwig gorinson making
the music alongside kendrick lamar this
movie some of its parts should not be
able to be the 11 you'd expect because
it's a [ __ ] 12. this movie is an a
plus this movie made the marvel universe
into the force of nature that it is and
this movie means so much to so many
people so it had some of the highest
expectations and absolutely nailed them
black panther is one of the greats in
comic book movies a movie is as good as
its villain and our number 13 has an
incredible villain because we lived with
him for quite some time avengers endgame
has to answer how do you take out thanos
and the beautiful thing about avengers
endgame is our heroes have lost this is
something that is the comeback from
empire this is something that is how you
solve trauma and it sets up phase four's
entire therapy session where everything
is trauma this movie is brutal and it
shows that even heroes have to think
outside the box that everything isn't
cookie cutter this solves the oh the
heroes will figure this thing out they
have to go through time travel they have
to find out new logistics they have to
team up in new and creative ways and it
gives us so many incredible
genre redefining moments in comic book
lore when cap wields mjolnir when thor
comes back when they blend the
incredible different tapestries of the
guardians of the galaxy tonality with
thor's tonality with caps tonality with
iron man's tonality it does all of that
while also giving amazing performances
in losing iron man in seeing heroes fall
we truly feel the ability of loss in
this genre and this movie
again establishes that trauma is
something that happens not just to the
heroes on screen but to us who love them
this movie proves that heroes can fall
and it's a very important one number 12
i love this movie and i feel like it's
sequel which you'll note i haven't
talked about yet because i do enjoy it a
little bit more are foundational to the
maturation again of the genre when you
look at 2006 it was a weird time in
comic book movies and a great example is
this movie had nickelback scoring it and
it was advertised as a katie holmes
rom-com you're right batman begins look
at the first batman begins trailer we
were so not sure what comic book movies
were because we were fresh off the
craziness of fox not knowing what they
were gonna land on leading into 2008
giving us iron man that this was a
batman begins that literally was like
katie holmes will save you from dawson's
creek then came out and showed us what a
year one bruce wayne could be in the
right hands it showed us that nolan had
this masterful broad strokes world of
gotham it gave us a chilling scarecrow
it gave us an incredible razal ghoul
with all those twists and turns and it
gave us a batman that yes had some flaws
i don't love the voice all the time but
i do love that he struck fear in
criminals that when we felt gotham it
didn't feel like something we could
visit because we wouldn't want to go
there it felt like the gotham of the
comic books and not just bruce wayne or
batman we finally got a batman that was
bruce wayne and batman and batman begin
still holds up number 11 is a western
number 11 is an r-rated movie with a
character we'd wanted to be r-rated for
a decade after being with them number 11
is the swan song of one of the best
comic book movie castings ever number 11
is logan logan is a movie that used
johnny cash's hurt throughout its
marketing and that's because this movie
was
hurt now famously trent rezner said once
johnny cash made hurt it wasn't his song
anymore to me this is the movie example
of seeing logan as not the x-men's logan
anymore this was now hugh jackman's
character in this universe and that
needed to be the end of his journey i
was apprehensive to have charles come
back in doctor strange because the
ending of logan is the ending of that
entire character set luckily it was
multiverse and it didn't really feel
like anything anyway but this
to me
is the culmination much like endgame
that finished off the fox universe a
universe that gave us the first shared
experience we really had in comic book
movies this movie had to be good because
if it didn't land it would have felt
like it sullied the entire journey first
this was an r-rated
western 310 to yuma-esque journey that
we earned through wanting this character
to get this closure and it is so close
to perfect i don't love the comic books
being in it short of that this movie is
is absolutely perfect and i love both
what it says how it's portrayed and the
experience of watching it top 10 you
lovelies avengers infinity war i was
dancing around thanos talking about
endgame but i think the reason infinity
war does such a good job at blending the
insane world marvel is built is because
it takes away those characters as your
lead and it makes your lead the guy
that's been behind the scenes the whole
time this movie was like hey what if
palpatine was the was the lead what if
our bad guy was the lead of this film
and then it's able to blend all of the
different flavors of the mcu one of the
strengths of the mcu is that ant-man is
a heist film doesn't feel like a space
opera guardians doesn't feel like tech
wizardry iron man doesn't feel like a
proud patriot rooting for the greater
good cap they all feel different how do
you put them together post age of ultron
how do you combine all those things one
of the reasons age of ultron didn't
quite work is the disparity of those
tones this showed you can do that right
and it focused on for my money one of
the greatest cinematic villains of all
time the thanos was right movement had
movement there are people that can see
where he's coming from because if you
sit on the 405 in l.a at rush hour you
consider those thoughts and the thing
about thanos is he wasn't mustached
whirling he just wanted to do what would
save the universe his goal was to save
unfortunately the cost of that was all
of us losing half of everything and
thanos wins this movie ends with the
empire strikes back of downers and
that's why in game had to come back from
that but for me the beats in this movie
the landing of so many action set pieces
and the ability to convey the mcu is
like nothing else we've ever seen in
cinema before infinity war was the
moment that i felt like they made that
in ink
this was saying the mcu was like nothing
that's come before and might not ever
come again this movie is a masterpiece
of what comic books can be number nine
the batman i'm ready for your recency
bias comments i am ready for your it was
boring i am ready for whatever is going
to come at me because this is my
experience and what i got to see
three times in four days because i fell
madly in love with this film is the
batman i've always wanted i love
christian bale's batman i love what they
were able to do at times with michael
keaton's batman i love mask of the
phantasm but i never felt like i got a
live action detective mystery set in
what i thought gotham would smell like
this movie has such an atmosphere you
can smell it this movie to me is also
the closest we'll ever get to david
fincher making a comic book movie who's
my favorite director and matt reeves
made a love letter to that style of film
this movie is dark it is grungy and most
of all it is modern i love that the
sensibilities aren't playing off the
golden age the silver age the bronze age
this is a batman now that's why nirvana
works this is someone that's our age
this is modernizing a character that's
archetypal bringing you all of the
texture and tone you need and making it
about today if batman was around today
he would deal with things like riddler's
trolls we as a society are dealing with
things like terrorism through cyber
attacks and people coming together for
all the wrong reasons and the way batman
stays relevant is he's one man fighting
insurmountable odds and one good man can
be enough and this is a man that goes
from being i am vengeance to being i am
hope and that's the difference between
this batman and other batman batman is
often a brute punching force he is a
thing that i don't think uses guns but
he uses aggressive violence to strike
fear this batman learned before our eyes
that fear doesn't mean anything if you
also don't inspire hope that's what
makes you a hero and this is masterfully
painted and this movie couldn't have
come at a time we needed a hero more the
batman number eight a movie that defied
what movies had been there's a long long
history of cinema movies have been
around a long time you know it hasn't
been around a long time giant team-up
spectacle summer blockbusters because it
just seems like a thing you don't do and
this movie made it so expendables exists
it accelerated the fast and furious
journey it is joss whedon's original
avengers now i know some people don't
love the dialogue but as a comic book
fan i think that some of this dialogue
is the most accurate to these characters
and yes some things don't work because
of when it came out but it started
everything there was no blueprint this
is the blueprint there was no history of
how to do this this was doing this and i
talked a lot about balancing tones in
infinity war and in game this one had to
do it first and it had to do it so early
this was only four years in the mcu now
we live in a time where you get four
comic book movies a year this was the
time you were lucky to get one and it
did it four years in that's insane they
didn't know where the mc was gonna go
and they went okay we're gonna make uh
movie number seven that's going to be
avengers okay well we'll figure it out
and it worked and it landed and it gave
us a great villain in loki it gave us
something unite and fight against it
gave us new york as a character like new
york often is in the comics it gave us
that incredible turning shot that at
this point is the matrix bullet time of
comic book movies that everyone tries to
replicate because that is what it feels
like whether what it feels like when you
see your heroes unite i think avengers
with time will find its way back into
the zeitgeist again and it is
the first to do something that needed to
be done for any of this to exist number
seven is perhaps the most important
comic book movie because it is a movie
that shows the punk rock for lack of a
better term attitude of marvel that got
them to be where they are now if you
look at comic books marvel often
represents the underdog story you got
your spider-man you got your you know
steve rogers you've got all these
scrappy characters that overcome the
odds that's what marvel is iron man was
a movie made from scraps in a cave just
like the character did iron man was a
fresh out of rehab young man trying to
put his life together that had the
bravado of 10 kings that had the acting
prowess of winning an oscar for chaplin
in his teens this movie is an
impossibility this is a director who had
done a bunch of incredible indies that
was about to change the world in
multiple different genres this was a
movie that had to be financed through
multiple like a distributor and a
different person supplying the money up
front like this movie was a series of
pieces that wasn't finished when they
started filming this movie was being
written as they went and it gives you
what laid the framework it is a hero
fighting against his id and ego it is
it's iron man fighting iron monger it's
what he could have been and it's someone
learning that just because that's what
he's been doing it doesn't mean that's
what he should be doing and it's a
sealist character that stanley invented
to be unlikable that was cast as one of
the most likable people ever that is so
good at playing unlikable this is a
perfect should not work and did work and
without iron man and 08 this list
wouldn't exist now this is one that is
this high up because of re-watchability
iron man is hillary watchable and i
often do and it is how we got here but i
think that guardians is the one that
steered everything left i don't think we
would have gone cosmic if james gunn's
guardians of the galaxy didn't land like
it did i don't think the mcu would have
accelerated to the amount of content it
puts out without guardians of the galaxy
and this was the first movie i doubted
in the mcu i love the mcu i've worked at
this since phase one i'm one of the few
in this space that remembers waiting
years between movies because it is a
younger genre of people that do
commentary in these movies but why in my
day it was a different world and i will
admit i was all about everything they
announced and when they announced the
guardians of the galaxy it was soon
after the disney thing and i had just
been listening to all of the hate on the
internet the internet's contagious
sometimes trolling gets even to me and i
try to be positive and i was like wait a
second they're gonna do that obscure
see-less series of heroes with a talking
tree and a raccoon and they're casting
and i literally thought it was a toy
grab i will admit that for only about a
month but that was about a month i
thought this was like okay they need to
make this something to profit from with
toys like lucasfilm and then this movie
came out and it might be the biggest
heart in the mcu this might be the
biggest beating heart of what it means
to be an outsider what it means to be a
loser what it means to feel like you're
not someone that belongs and if there's
anything that the marvel universe does
well it's make outsiders feel like they
belong if you go to any con you go to
any fan screening everyone that doesn't
feel like they have a family has a
family in the mcu and the guardians of
the galaxy showed us that on screen in
space top five we are into the top five
and we're kicking it off with the merc
with the mouth
this movie was tiny
shouldn't have existed got leaked
and exists out of sheer force of nerd
will ryan reynolds was born to play
deadpool it just took him a long time to
find the suit he came out as deadpool
wade reynolds is his name
wade wilson is the person that ryan
rodney reynolds is just without the suit
and what this movie did was it showed us
why we waited the technology had to
catch up the budget had to be just right
and this movie was so good at being
nimble this movie was so good again at
punk rock sensibilities that they cut an
entire chunk of the budget because they
were like oh no that's allocated for pr
that's not your money to use and the
scene in the film where he leaves his
guns in the car is literally them
shaving 20 million dollars off the
budget and you wouldn't know that unless
i just told you or you read it before
because the movie flows so well at being
pure controlled chaos which is deadpool
this movie also makes a character that
doesn't work all the time in comics work
through every single beat if there's one
thing you'll learn from both deadpool
comics and a lot of deadpool fans is
that when in the wrong hands there's
nothing more annoying than deadpool but
when in the right hands you realize that
deadpool is a character that wears a
mask not to hide his identity but to
protect you from seeing his gross face
he is an exposed nerve as a character he
is the ultimate in using comedy as a
defense mechanism and this movie uses
comedy as a defense mechanism this is a
movie that is about love this is a movie
that's about lost this is a movie about
cancer this is 50 50 meets the notebook
with pegging this movie is able to do
everything deadpool doesn't just want to
do it's everything deadpool needed to do
to legitimize him as the character that
he needed to be and this movie is so
good it actually changed the comic books
this movie
is
when every single person loves the art
they're making and every single frame
shows for it number four another lot of
comments coming for this one i'm ready
for y'all bring him on the dark knight
this is not a joker movie comments 7
through 52 this is a batman movie with
the joker in it yes the joker is a very
important character yes i think the
joker is the best acting i've ever seen
including brando including pacino
including whatever other scorsese actor
you want to throw at me the joker is a
character that's able to surprise
himself in line delivery and give us an
audience an experience we hadn't seen
before in acting but that only works
because of the other side which is
batman batman is about doing the right
thing and accepting escalation the last
frame of batman begins is things are
going to get worse the dark knight works
because things got worse and we didn't
lose batman the movie the dark knight is
about two white knights one has to go
dark aaron eckhart gets no love when it
comes to this movie because everyone's
so busy talking about heath ledger as
they should but aaron eckhart is able to
show you what absolute power corrupts
absolutely or what corruption when seen
and facing it to such a level can do to
a person this is a movie about love this
is a movie about corruption this is a
movie about politics this is a movie
about what it means to be human that has
jaws running around it the chaos element
that is the joker heath ledger has
something like 17 minutes of screen time
yes there's some of the best 17 minutes
ever put to film heath ledger's the
reason i do this i want to be an actor
because heath ledger that led me to this
job i'm saying nothing disparaging heath
ledger what bothers me is every single
person that talks about the dark knight
decides that it's a joker movie and lets
everything else go even if this was a
joker movie it'd be number four but you
need to re-watch that movie without all
of these expectations without all of the
20 years of us getting more and more
cynical and appreciate the fact that
christopher nolan ignored everything
that had came before
let the foundation of batman begins be
what he launched off on and made one of
the most masterful pieces of film not
even in the comic book genre we've ever
seen that has some of the best
performances we will ever get and it's
about what it means to have hope i hate
the disrespect of the dark knight
put some respect on it number four
number three is a big old surprise for
me not in the list i made this list in
my experience of it when they announced
spider-man into the spider-verse i was
so
confused because for me the spider-verse
story was a really fun way to introduce
new characters and why would you go hey
let's skip a miles per hour story and
bring in a ton of new characters and i
was worried for miles morales i was like
man we got peter parker they should have
like someone like andrew garfield be a
mentor of miles morales they're gonna
bring him in an animation i was just
worried about everything then they
announced it was lord miller and i was
like okay i will no longer go into this
with any expectations except for i'm
gonna love its humor and then it gave me
a movie that was able to not only
explain quantum theory to kids it's so
witty but it also gave me six of my
favorite spider people this movie
is able to do what i think most other
team movies try and fail at i love when
a movie can go hey we're gonna bring in
all of these characters much like
guardians of the galaxy and you're gonna
care about all of them do you know how
much i cared about spider-man noir
before into the spider-verse not so much
i'm the biggest spider-man fan i know
and this movie gave me so many
characters i love this movie gave me a
sinister six effectively this movie gave
me
multiversal twists and turns on
characters i love like doc hawk with one
of the best voice casts you could ever
hope for and it reminded me what it
means to be spider-man we hadn't had
that direct of a path of what it means
to be spider-man in so long there was a
void of what spider-man was in the pop
culture zeitgeist he wasn't the number
one spot like spider-man often is and it
gave us a new twist on with great power
comes great responsibility it gave us a
whole new motto anyone could wear the
mask is now just as synonymous to me as
spider-man that's from
this movie a movie i didn't know would
land gave me a new take on my favorite
comic book character this movie is
perfect in every frame it didn't just
change animation it changed spiderman
number two is for greg and greg only
greg you can edit this out cause it's
just for you they're gonna go 3-1 that's
weird captain america winter soldier
number two you heard it here first
uh-huh do you greg it's not what i hear
with your hot take videos oh is it
overrated and i number two is my number
two
is my number two comic book movie
overrated greg i'm sorry
let me get back to it audience this is a
movie with
multiple villains that all are
legitimized in their journey even arnim
zola which is a character that shouldn't
work it makes sense where he's coming
from and that's insane this is a movie
with i think the best action in the mcu
next to daredevil on netflix which if we
included tv shows this would be an eight
hour video because daredevil netflix
this is the best cinematic action i
think hard stop between the knife fight
the elevator everything else this is a
movie about distrust you've got a
character captain america that literally
represents being spangled being a badge
being something that represents trust
and the opening of the movie he's in a
different suit which lays the groundwork
for not trusting the systems if there's
one thing i've learned is in life not
serious one of the biggest things i've
ever learned is adulthood doesn't happen
it's the moment you realize there is no
adulthood we're all just figuring it out
my biggest piece of adulthood has been
learning the systems that we believe in
aren't actually there always to help us
so you can't just blindly trust these
systems this is a movie about that
starring a character that often is
written so poorly he represents all the
blind patriotism that gets us in trouble
this movie subverts not just movie norms
but life norms and does it with
incredible action incredible villains
and it reestablishes the entire mcu by
dismantling the only system we knew
within the mcu shield it makes us
distrust everything we've ever seen this
movie much like logan being a launching
point in a maturation much like iron man
3 being about trauma that grows us up
this movie is about what it is to be an
adult do not trust anything at face
value do not believe what other people
are always telling you trust yourself
even if that meant going against
everything you thought you believed in
everything is about your journey and
winter soldier especially through the
lens of steve abandoning what he felt
was told to him for what he felt was
right while beautifully illustrated
through the winter soldier himself
through bucky having to discover what it
is to be a person having to put his life
back together having to have two
characters from opposing sides reprogram
themselves as brothers
this movie is better than for me any
captain america comic and this movie is
for me what it means to be an adult
hopefully you guys got to see what i
thought of cap all right so i've got
some honorable mentions before we get to
number one these are videos i would also
love to do tell greg my first one is
batman returns i think batman returns is
very important in the early days of
comic book movies in being a bold
trendsetter and being a foundational bit
of all of this i just personally don't
rewatch it as often so it didn't make my
top 25 but it's really close x-men first
class is a movie that went against the
universe they had already built and made
an x-men movie that felt more like an
x-men movie i feel like x-men first
class is much closer to the x-men than
the bryan singer mutant movies we got
unfortunately we never got to see that
go forward but i think that movie on its
own is way more important than people
give you credit for it via proven data
is one of the great adaptations of
graphic novels in that it is able to
translate and adapt the medium very very
accurately and i feel like this is a
graphic novel that is more and more
topical every day and this movie doesn't
get brought up enough but again it's not
something that i feel like i revisit
enough to have on the list but i think
it's one of the most important comic
book movies joker's tricky it definitely
makes my favorites list but i think it
has much like fight club and a lot of
wolf of wall street fans the worst fans
and pr out there i think the people that
are loudest about joker don't understand
exactly what it's saying or i could be
wrong and they do exactly understand it
i like that joker is a dangerous movie i
like that joker represents when people
go too far into their beliefs this is a
movie that actually made me nauseous
this is a movie that upset me watching
this is a movie that made me worry about
humanity and i cannot deny that art is
anything that makes you feel i love this
art it just worries me that the wrong
people love this art so passionately so
i couldn't in good conscience feel like
it's a movie about what i think comic
books are which is hope this is like
when you lose hope and i think that's
beautiful for emotions but i think
that's terrifying for humanity and then
we're gonna say a few that i love for
good measure watchmen i think is a very
loyal adaptation i think the twist at
the end was needed to make it work in
the medium i think men in black is so
slept on it was a malibu comic which was
then bought by marvel so technically if
we have the secret wars event we could
have vincent d'onofrio fighting vincent
de nofrio as someone that wants some
sugar and water there's a lot of comic
book movies that got us here but that
top 25 is just where i feel like are the
important foundational ones and my
favorites to revisit if you want 26
through 50 hit up greg greg
greg.gmail.com no leave a comment below
let me know which ones you agree with
which ones you disagree with let me give
you my number one though this is i think
the greatest
favoritest bestest comic book movie of
all time i made a fairly impassioned
video for my mcu countdown and yes we
are sticking with the mcu and if you
guys want a more extended version of the
answer to this question my number one is
spiderman no way home and i am very
understanding that this came out in
december it is now september i am aware
that that is nine months but i haven't
stopped thinking about when i started
believing in comic book movies as a
thing we could get when i saw there was
a wizard magazine which is a trade
publication about comic books and there
was there was a poster that said parody
in really small letters in the bottom
your boy was five did note the word
parody meant so i literally put this
poster up my wall thinking we were
getting a james cameron directed
leonardo dicaprio starring spider-man
movie because that was a poster which
means it's real for about two years i
embarrassingly didn't ask anyone but
parody men and i just stayed hopeful for
this movie that never came to my theater
so from like it might have been six but
from like six to eight or thereabouts i
was waiting for a movie that never
existed spider-man no way home ended up
being that movie because
it was a movie that didn't just take how
i felt about spider-man as a kid it
didn't just take other people's favorite
spider-man it was the culmination of all
of the different spider-men in a way
that shouldn't have worked i was saying
earlier into the spider-verse i thought
was a way to sell toys and bring in new
characters i was afraid no way home
would be a way to pat someone on the
head that loved toby pat someone that
had the lavender garfield and launched
tom holland it wasn't it made andrew
garfield and toby maguire our uncle ben
for our universe it gave aunt may the
power of the character that she needed
to have from the j michael strozinski
run it gave us the green goblin we
always deserved it gave us damn near the
sinister six i never thought we'd had
since they were introduced in spider-man
annual back in 1964.
these are the stories that made me a
comic book fan and they were able to not
just put one into a two and a half hour
movie they were able to blend them all
using the medium that wouldn't work in
comic books i love no way home because
this wouldn't work as a comic because
you don't have the connection to the
drawings of these characters like you do
with toby mcguire and andrew garfield
and tom holland when you look at andrew
garfield not only do you see his
spider-man but you think of all the
emotions you have with him in interviews
if you watch them with him in other
movies if you watch them the medium of
film is more than what's on the screen
it's your emotional connection to
everything you're seeing
no way home would take
volumes of comic books because we've
lived with toby for 20 years we've lived
with andrew for 10 years we've lived
with tom for damn near half a decade all
of our emotional connection to all of
that plus how we feel about spider-man
all got brought together through
incredible technology through trust in
john watts and john watts got to make
the spider-man movie that he waited six
movies to tell the origin for that he
waited to give his flourishing style of
directing for that we earned by being
patient this movie couldn't have existed
until this year and this story couldn't
have existed in another medium and none
of this could have existed if we didn't
stay passionate about spider-man if we
didn't believe in these heroes and none
of this would have worked if we hadn't
been such fans of the other 24 movies i
listed on the way here this is to me the
ultimate butterfly effect of being a
comic book movie fan and it stuck the
landing it is a perfect experience for
me and it's one of the best two and a
half hour times i've had in a movie
theater and i can't wait for it to get
re-released i just realized this is
practically a commercial for the
spider-man no way homer release
available september 6th or something i'm
not sure when it comes out but you know
i'll be there i need those 11 more
minutes this has been very long if you
want to know a little bit more about how
i feel about it from the other side from
the comic book side i do talk about it
in the mcu countdown that video is also
on this channel in this playlist i could
do a couple hours on no way home i have
on this channel this list
is every different studio to me loving
art and loving what we love and why
we're here so any of these 25 any of the
honorable mentions any of the 26 through
50 i didn't get to talk about it's all
out of love and i think a lot of people
get cynical about show business but it's
coming from people that love it as much
as you do next time you want to talk
[ __ ] about me which is going to come
because i put your movie up whatever
number know that it's coming from a
place of love i love all this stuff so i
hope you love it too i hope that uh this
list gave you at least some perspective
on where i come from so you can be like
oh i hadn't thought of it that way or oh
i didn't realize this is how you felt
not a place of me saying that one movie
is better than another this is my
experience with this art and i hope you
experience it differently because you
have a different life leave your list
below i'd love to read which ones you
enjoy how you rank them what your
favorites are and i will read the
comments up until people get cheating
we'll see how long that lasts but i love
you i appreciate you thank you for being
so welcoming here on my comic corner
here at the reject nation please comment
like subscribe all the things i always
say too fast greg any notes
just just leave
okay we should go
bye guys
[Laughter]
[Music]